coronavirus starts to dip in arizona
florida and texas while members of
government consider new lockdowns
anarchists finally begin burning books
in portland and president trump goes
after tick-tock i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure their internet join
them
expressvpn.com slash ben well i have to
note that there's something that's very
weird going on
in this country and in media and that is
the sense that things are constantly
getting worse with regard to covet when
the evidence that things are getting
worse with regard to covid
really is not spectacular and what i
mean by that is obviously we've seen
more deaths over the past month there's
just no question we've seen more
infections over the past
month but as a percentage of infection
deaths continue to decline
as he as a running tab in terms of
hospitalizations
deaths continue to decline
hospitalizations have started to decline
in places like arizona florida and texas
and it is also worthy of note that other
countries are now experiencing unrest in
the streets over lockdown
so all of the talk about how in the
united states it's all red state blue
state kind of stuff only these evil
conservatives want to
stop the lockdowns and reopen the
economy they are literally having mass
protests
in the streets of berlin over the
lockdown in israel they've had mass
protests in the streets
over everything from unemployment to
lockdown specifically targeted lockdown
against religious communities is one of
the implications
this sort of stuff has been happening
all over the world because it turns out
that when you lock
hundreds of millions of people indoors
for months on end
and tell them that in order to be safe
from a virus that largely kills people
who are above the age of 80
most people who are young are not going
to abide by that and most people who are
young
are going to start going out again
they're going to start participating in
everyday life again
and let's be real about this they
probably should if you're 20 years old
there is no reason for you to stay home
other than you're afraid that you're
going to infect grandma that's pretty
much
it and that means that when you visit
grandma grandma should wear a mask and
you should wear a mask and you should
socially distance and that's all
and the notion that large numbers of
young people are in danger from this or
dying from this it is not statistically
true
and i i get the sense that there is this
real gap
in the american level of panic about
this thing and the actual fact
on the ground about how deadly this
thing is i think that if you asked
regular everyday americans how many
people out of a thousand who get coveted
do you think are going to die of this
thing
the average american would probably tell
you out of out of 100 people
10 will die out of a thousand people 50
to 100 will die
and that's not true that is not true if
you are under
the age of 25 you are not dying from
this statistically speaking
okay if you are under the age of 55 you
are
almost certainly not dying of this
statistically speaking
in fact in the united states we've seen
something on the order of 150 000 deaths
when you break it down by group i was
talking with somebody who was
actually a member of the group that
wrote the cdc guidelines
over over the shabbat weekend and and
this guy was saying
that the average age of death in the
united states from covenant this is true
according to the cdc the average age
average
is 80 which means that half of the
people
who have died of this are above the age
of 80 half
okay and the truth is that nearly
everybody who has died of this is above
the age of 70.
okay the the cdc puts out these stats
regularly and here are the stats that
are the latest stats this is from
late july in terms of absolute number of
deaths
by age group in the united states and
this would be out of a total of
some hundred thousand deaths that that
were reported to the cdc as of like
mid july because there's been again this
uptick over the past few months
and there's late reporting okay so this
is out of maybe a hundred thousand
deaths
that were reported to the cdc as of mid
to
mid to late july hey if you are under
the age of 25 out of those hundred
thousand deaths
there have been 1236 deaths
okay if you're under the age of 25 in a
population
that probably has 100 million people
under the age
of 25. there have been a grand total of
14 deaths below the age of five
there have been a grand total of 23
deaths below the age of 15.
is we're not talking about large numbers
of young people who are getting this and
dying of this
nor are we talking about large numbers
of young people between the ages of 25
and 34 who are dying of this there have
been a grand total
of again according to the cdc and is out
of about 100 000 deaths that are
reported as of mid july
there were 200 deaths aged 25 to 34.
and when you look at the curves from the
cdc
in terms of actual numbers of overall
death in these age groups
covid represents an extraordinarily
small percentage of the overall number
of deaths in these age groups which is
why
if you look at the flu you should be if
you're a parent you should be much more
scared of your kid getting the flu than
you should about your kid getting
covered
no doubt and without a doubt like you're
16 to 20 times as likely to die from the
flu if you're under the age of five
then you are to die of covid which again
should not be a surprise we've known
this for a long time and this is why
it's so maddening
when you see our experts say things like
well you know it's true that mostly old
people are getting this but it could
happen to anybody
statistically speaking it really can't
statistically speaking
the the people who are dying of this are
generally older which means you protect
those populations and then if you wish
to reach anything like herd immunity
what you actually want
what you actually want is not to shut
down the spread you want young healthy
people to actually get it
over time if you want to return to
immunity and i know herd immunity became
this sort of
bad term that you're not allowed to use
anymore because we're all supposed to
sit around waiting for the vaccine but
that was always
that was always a foolish notion that
herd immunity was completely off the
table
especially because again we can look
back at sweden there's a lot of talk
about sweden was going for herd immunity
look how badly they did it
okay sweden never locked down sweden
actually saw a gdp growth in their last
quarter
and sweden now has a declining level of
cases and nearly
no death why well because it turns out
that the
immunity to the herd immunity rates to
this thing may not in fact be 70 or 80
as originally supposed it may be as low
as 20 or 30 percent
because it is possible that a lot of
people have t cell immunity meaning that
if you had a cold in the recent past you
have a certain level of immunity already
built up to covet
it it is maddening when you hear experts
say things i mean and anthony fauci will
say stuff like this on national tv
they'll say well well it's true that
this is mostly affecting older people
young people can
be hurt by this too okay well while it
is true that death mostly affects older
people death can affect younger people
too
there are lots of things in life that
also affect younger people irritable
bowel syndrome affects younger people it
is also much more prevalent among the
elderly
the question is not can a bad thing
happen to you the question is what are
the chances
of the bad thing happening to you and
that is the thing that we should be
focused on but nobody seems to be
focused on that
right now there's a swiss study of zero
prevalence
trying to figure out what exactly the
infection fatality rate was of covid by
age
and what it showed is that if you are
under the age of 10 you're basically
more likely to be struck by lightning
than to die of covid if you are
if you're below the age of 20 same thing
is true
even if you are looking at the
generalized overall covet death rates
the
the infection fatality rate so the cdc
is now estimating that the
infection fatality rate could be
anywhere from 0.2 to 0.6 which is
something i've been saying for literally
months
pretty much since this started even you
take the upper end estimate 0.6
i think people don't understand what
that means that means if if 1 000 people
get covered 994 of them will live
now that does not necessarily mean that
everybody who lives is going to be
completely undamaged by it
but we don't actually have the data and
how many people are damaged
or what the damage looks like so instead
we see these anecdotal horror stories
of people who have zero lung function or
we hear these kind of vague statements
that people will have heart damage we
don't know how much heart damage
okay that's panic porn it is if you
don't have hard data that's panic porn
and panic porn sells papers and it and
it moves clicks
the panic porn is not good for your
brain and it ain't good for your soul
and doesn't allow you to
to calculate on an everyday level what
sort of risks you should be taking as a
responsible human being
frankly it is maddening that we have
continued to
act as though this thing is equally
deadly for all age groups and that
everybody should be treated equally in
the population in terms of lockdown it
doesn't make any sense at all
like none again the fact is that this is
disproportionately affecting elderly
people because elderly people
have more underlying conditions and are
more likely likely to die period
and the the fact is that if you look at
death from all causes
among people who are above the age of 85
death of all clauses between essentially
july between between januar between
sorry february 1st
and july 25th death of all causes if
you're over the age of 85
467 000 people died in that period above
the age of
85 in this country and 44 000 of them
died of covid
hey what does that mean it means a lot
of people died of covet above the age of
85 like a lot in fact that's the single
largest population group in terms of who
died from covet
is people above the age of 85. out of
the 6.5 million americans who are in
that age group
some 44 000 people died in that age
group and it is by far
by a plurality the largest age group for
death
that doesn't mean that each one of those
deaths isn't tragedy it means that when
you're trying to figure out who goes
back to work 85 year olds are not the
ones who are staffing the workplace
now again if you've got underlying
conditions if you've got obesity or
diabetes
then maybe you should think about
distancing and wearing a mask and doing
all the things that
you should do but if you are younger i
think that
all the talk about how we can never talk
hurt immunity we can never like i don't
know
what everybody's plan is i'm not hearing
a plan and if the plan is wait for a
vaccine
that plan has some holes in it it has
some serious holes in it okay so
in a second we're going to talk about
the wait for a vaccine plan we're also
going to talk about what's happening in
arizona florida and texas where we were
hearing doom and gloom
everyone was going to die and it got
pretty bad in terms of the
deaths per day in places like florida
arizona and texas and now they've hit
the downslope
we'll talk about also how this does not
correlate with lockdown it doesn't
okay the notion that lockdown saved
these states california never stopped
locking down
and california has had the latest peak
of any of these states it turns out
these states were not experiencing a
second wave they never experienced a
first wave they were just experiencing
the first wave
and now the question is if there even
will be a second wave depending on how
many people actually got this
gonna get so you know the panic
is is this a moral panic at this point
it it may well be that doesn't mean any
dangerous doesn't mean it real
it's dangerous it's real you should take
precautions to make sure that people who
are vulnerable don't get it
but we are now making risk calculations
not based on any hard data we're making
risk calculations based on the panic
porn put out there by the media and yes
by some public health experts whose
literal job like a lawyer you know i've
been
i've acted as a lawyer your job as a
lawyer is risk mitigation you go to your
client you say here are all the risks
right in your business we need to take
care of all of those risks if you are a
quote unquote health policy expert your
job is to mitigate risk
to human life and if that means scaring
people then you scare people
and if it means kind of overstating the
case a little bit then you do that too
but you are never asked to take into
account the countervailing
problems with locking down entire
societies which we'll discuss in just
one second first
let's talk about the fact that right now
you're paying too much for your wireless
now can you really afford to pay too
much for what can you afford to pay too
much for anything right now the answer
of course
is no who is your wireless provider by
the way t verizon t-mobile what if i
told you
pure talk usa uses the exact same
network as one of those carriers
the same towers the same exact coverage
but literally cost you half
how do they make it so affordable well
there are no retail stores so there's
low overhead you're not funding their
billion dollar ad campaigns you're only
paying for the data you need
there's no contract no excessive fees
you'll enjoy unlimited talk
text and two gigs of data all for just
20 bucks a month that's correct the
average person is saving 400
a year on their wireless bill so grab
your mobile phone dial pound 250 say ben
shapiro when you do
you get this screaming deal and save 50
off your first month
again that's pound two five zero say
keyword ben shapiro there is
no reason to waste money on gigs of data
you ain't using there is no reason why
you should be spending like up to twice
as much on your cell phone bill when you
could be spending half as much
using pure talk dial pound 250 say ben
shapiro and when you get that
when you do that you get an amazing deal
and you save 50 off your very
first month you're talking about
unlimited talk text and two gigs of data
all for just 20 a month the average
person saving 400 bucks a year on their
wireless bill by using
pure talk pound 250 say keyword ben
shapiro to make the magic happen for you
okay so
again all we heard for literally months
was arizona florida texas we're all
going to die
it is just as big it's like new york
it's like 12 new york it's a bunch of
new york's all over the place the
hospitals are going to be overwhelmed
well now it seems that that is simply
not the case it seems that we may be
looking
at the at the basically the end of this
thing
in florida and arizona and texas at
least for the moment you know we don't
know what's going to happen come the
fall
but again it's hard to see how the
spread is going to be much more dramatic
than it just was in florida
arizona and texas so here is a chart
okay the chart shows you what happened
in new york versus what happens in
arizona florida and texas combined
anybody who compared these places is
being an idiot that solid line right
there is the number of deaths
you can see a blue solid line from new
york and it goes sky high
sky high all the way up to number of
deaths per day per million new york went
up to like 40 deaths per day per million
in the state arizona florida and texas
combined
never went above 10. never okay so
it was never like new york it was never
like new york you can see new york just
got overwhelmed
new york got hit really hard and more
than anything new york did not protect
its elderly
elderly homes and that meant a lot of
elderly people died because guess what
elderly people are the people who are
mostly dying from this again the number
of americans who have died
of this disease total under the age of
55 in the united states
at least as reported as of mid july by
the cdc
under 11 000 out of a hundred thousand
and this is this is a disease that is
mostly killing elderly people that does
not mean it's not dangerous it doesn't
mean don't be careful for the thousandth
time
okay so florida and arizona and texas
you've also started to see the cases
come down you go back to that other
chart for a second you can see
the dotted line there's a red dotted
line and what the red dotted line shows
is cases so you can see new york spiked
it looks exactly like the curve you
didn't want so new york spiked it spiked
in terms of cases and spiked in terms of
death
and then you can see on that red dotted
line arizona florida and texas they
spiked in terms of cases
and they kind of gradually rose in terms
of death and now
presumably all of this will start to
recede as the trailing indicator that is
death
you know goes up a little bit and then
it'll start to come down again this is
all courtesy of covettracking.com
okay and then you can look at the at the
second wave
up you can also look at
when you compare cases and deaths on the
same scale and
access so the here is the media telling
you
you know exactly how bad things were
going to be in terms of cases and deaths
you can see
the deaths remained extraordinarily low
throughout
right they have remained very very low
throughout the cases created this huge
mountain of cases
mainly identified cases lots of
asymptomatics were being identified here
lots of cases that were not particularly
dangerous
and i think here we should note that
there is this weird tendency out there
to think that if a person whose 30 gets
coveted and then recovers from it
something bad just happened
if a person got coveted and they're 30
and they recovered from it and they're
not harmed by it
an extraordinarily good thing happened
not just for the person not just because
they're superman and can walk around
but also because that person is no
longer capable of carrying the disease
the way that you approach her immunity
is by making people not able to carry
around the disease not to be
vectors of transmission now you can see
here
by the way on this chart again courtesy
of coveted tracking.com from you know
weiss
who does a great job putting these
charts together you can see
exactly how the lockdowns had no effect
in arizona florida and texas
and then as soon as the protest began
you can see the thing the thing starts
to
starts to spike right the lockdowns
kicked in late march
okay the the case load had already
started to rise a little bit it
basically was flat
then the reopenings happened the
beginning of may it completely stayed
flat
then the protest happened at the end of
may and then literally two weeks later
the number of cases starts climbing so
for all of this talk about how
the protest did nothing and turns out
that that also was not true
also worth noting there are certain
states that never reopen and they're
having spikes in cases
hawaii had a huge spike in number of
coveted cases per day per million
hawaii okay they've shut down travel you
literally cannot vacation in hawaii
and hawaii is that it's an island in the
middle of nowhere
they've had huge spikes you're starting
to see spikes in alaska
it turns out that basically everybody's
gonna get hit by this
and the only thing you can do is protect
the vulnerable which by the way was the
recommendation in terms of policy
that i've been putting out there for for
literally months i mean i had a full
episode devoted to the idea
of what two israeli scientists called
controlled avalanche early on
their suggestion was if you're going to
approach herd immunity the way you
approach herd immunity
is you actually want people who are
younger to get it and not pass it to
older people
if you're a part of a non-vulnerable
population it is a very good thing for
you to have it
not on a personal level obviously nobody
wants to get sick
but in terms of approaching herd
immunity just in the same way that a
vaccine
like you may never get the disease that
you get the vaccine for the vaccine is
an attempt to prevent you from becoming
a vector of transmission
for that disease and that's why people
have vaccinations
the same thing holds true when it comes
to herd immunity and getting something
like covet
this doesn't mean you should willy-nilly
go out and have coveted parties because
again we don't know all the risks at
this point but
here's the reality of it as this thing
makes its way through the population
there's no way to stop it
and anyone who is telling you that there
is a clear obvious way to stop it is
wrong
japan is seeing a spike in cases right
now japan has extraordinarily high
levels of both masking
and of social and of social listening
and people who obey the the rules
basically and they're singing spikes too
so what that means is if you actually
want to have at any point something
approaching herd immunity how about this
how about we trash back in the
populations that are most healthy
we protect the populations that are
least healthy you know that would
include opening the schools you know who
are the healthiest populations kids
so if kids all get this and pass it to
each other and don't kill their parents
which by the way we have not seen a lot
of evidence of transmission from kids to
parents
there was one lab study that came out
over the weekend suggesting that kids
can pass it and and and have the ability
to pass it but
there are studies in switzerland and
iceland in australia and and sweden
suggesting kids are really not passing
this thing very much
okay then schools are actually a great
way of taking an entire population off
the table as carriers of the disease
with the ability to pass it it's not a
bad thing
meanwhile the experts continue to to
act as though panic is warranted
concern is always warranted concern is
always warranted but panic
is not warranted and they're putting out
not great information so for example dr
fauci who again
i think he's doing the best he can i
think man is an american hero for his
work on hiv
i also think that his assessment of the
situation throughout
has been dicey i think he has made
mistakes for sure
and i think that the fact that fauci
will say things like
we need to lock down harder while
simultaneously refusing to answer
questions about
protests that probably ceded huge
increases in places like california
there there's something overtly
political to that anyway here is anthony
fauci
late last week testifying before
congress and saying our big problem in
the united states is we didn't lock down
harder like europe
if you look at what happened in europe
when they shut down or lock down or went
to shelter in place
however you want to describe it they
really did it to the tune of about 95
plus percent of the country did that
when you actually look at what we did
even though we shut down even though it
created a great deal of difficulty
we really functionally shut down only
about 50 percent
in the sense of the totality of the
country okay but
most of the country didn't have case
loads like this
and by the way he happens not to be
right about this like on an actual level
he happens not to be right about this
the united states the united states shut
down
about the same level in terms of
voluntary social distancing
as germany apple does this thing they
call mobility trends
right mobility trends are basically they
use their data
to track how people are making routing
requests
like how much people are moving okay so
here's what germany's
chart looks like so what you've seen is
that in april
in late march basically all of their
numbers on walking driving transit
plunged by more than 60
and now they are back above sort of
baseline
they've increased since april and
since since april they've increased
they're walking about 63 they're driving
about 59
they're transferred about 36 percent
okay now let's look at the united states
chart
why look at that it looks almost
identical oh goodness
it looks as though the united states
plunged almost about 60 and then
has climbed back up 54 driving 45
walking and 46
transit so um
where's the giant difference exactly
like where's the alex berrinson gets
credit for that one it's a good
good call by him the the the notion that
we have that we didn't lock down here is
just not true i lived in la the whole
time we locked down hard we locked down
as hard
the difference between the united states
and germany is not the level of lockdown
and germany
is that this thing was not seeded all
that heavily in germany it was very
heavily seated in the united states by
early march
the first cases known in the united
states were happening by late january
which is why once it exploded in new
york it really exploded in new york
it's again the the experts a lot of the
things the experts are saying here just
do not seem to jibe with the
with the scientific reality and again
you have to ask which experts because
there are plenty of experts who disagree
with the idea that lockdowns are the be
all end-all here
and if we ever hope to come out of this
thing i think this pipe dream that we're
gonna lock down until there's a vaccine
i don't know what anybody's talking
about we were told flat in the curve the
curve has been flattened you know what
didn't get overwhelmed
the hospitals in florida or arizona or
texas or by the way california
so last week i was feeling sick i went
over to get a covet test in california
i walked in went to the ucla hospital
within two and a half hours they had my
test results the er was completely empty
completely empty they were not being
threatened in terms of icu i mean i
asked the nurses are you being
threatened in terms of icu by the way
thank god
i'm covered negative and i say thank god
not because i was experiencing heavy
symptoms or anything but because
my parents who are in their 60s were
very careful about this stuff right
i didn't want to be coveted positive
because then i would have to isolate and
all of that
so here's the rule okay guys if you have
it go isolate if you are near elderly
people particularly but generally
because you don't want this thing
passing willy-nilly throughout society
in ways that you can't control
two young people should go back to work
young people should who are healthy
young people should go back to work
and this is why the conversation
happening about schools right now is not
in any way related to reality
wear the masks socially distance try not
to pass this thing because
realistically speaking what you don't
want is what you call sort of an
epidemic overhang where if you hit herd
immunity at let's say 30
it moves so fast through the population
it takes out 35 of the population
without it moving slowly kind of want to
you know
slowly approach herd immunity but the
notion that we're going to lock down
forever like
even in germany they're looking at this
going no we're not
francis said we're not re-locking down
so i don't know what the hell we're
talking about here
here and get some more of this in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact
that you need more sleep i need more
sleep so let me tell you over the
weekend
my uh sister-in-law got married it was
beautiful and
we uh we had an event over the weekend
it was social innocence mass the whole
deal
this necessitated that i sleep in a bed
not my own because we had to spend
shabbat
in a different part of los angeles this
meant i was not on my helix sleep
mattress
if i look haggard and horrible to you it
is because i was not on my helix sleep
mattress that helix sleep mattress
is unbelievable helix sleep has a quiz
it takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences
to the perfect mattress for you whether
you're a side sleeper or a hot sleeper
whether you like a plush or from bed
with helix there's no more confusion and
no more compromising
helix sleep is rated the number one
mattress by gq and wired magazine
cnn called it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on
just head on over to helix leap.com ben
take their two minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights at risk free they'll even
pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you will helix
is offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders right now just for my
listeners get up to 200 bucks off at
helixsleep.com
that's helixsleep.com and go check them
out right now
helixsleep.com for up to 200 off okay so
when there are people that i've had on
this show who i consider to be experts
on all of this who i think are just
scaring the living hell out of people
and i don't know
what they are saying is is supremely
useful so
dr debra burks over the weekend she did
a bunch of interviews this after nancy
pelosi ripped her up and down for
apparently being some sort of trump
stooge which is just insane nancy pelosi
has the has the amount of information in
that brain
could fit probably on the head of a pin
uh almost certainly inside the brain of
an act
in any case here was dr debra burks
explaining that the virus is
extraordinarily widespread
but i want to be very clear what we're
seeing today is different from march and
april
it is extraordinarily widespread it's
into the rural as equal urban areas and
to everybody who lives in a rural area
you are not immune or protected from
this virus
nobody's saying that anybody is
protected from this virus nobody's
saying that anybody's protected from
this virus
but the sort of like panic that you're
all going to die if you get the virus
and that the virus is going to kill you
if you're young and you're healthy so
you got to stay out of school this is
what's leading to the insanity of
teachers in iowa
sending the governor of iowa their own
obituaries their obituaries
saying that they're going to die if they
go back to school the data on this is
extraordinarily
lacking canada has been sending people
back to school
sweden never shut down at schools is my
understanding
the only case that we know of in which
there is an outbreak of school was in
israel and we still don't know whether
the kids were passing it to the adults
and also there's a difference between
kids under the age of 10 and kids over
the age of ten this is something that we
know
and dr deborah burks also says maybe you
should wear a mask at home now again
i'm not going to disagree that if you've
got an elderly person in the home or
somebody you think is vulnerable they
should
so my kids are going to camp now they're
going to camp because they're small
children and guess what small children
need to be with other small children
and i'm not afraid they're going to get
sick because they're small children my
parents are 65.
i talked to several doctors and what
they suggested is when my parents come
over
my parents should socially distance
outside and they should be wearing
n95 masks and my parents are doing that
is that fun for them
no but is it is it smart to completely
isolate my kids for all of time
i don't think so either so i want the
best of both worlds which at this point
means protect my parents but make sure
that my kids can also do the things they
need to do here's dr burks
but more importantly if you're in
multi-generational households and here's
an outbreak
in your rural area or in your city you
need to really consider
wearing a mask at home assuming that
you're positive if you have
individuals in your households with
comorbidities this
epidemic right now is different and it's
wide it's more widespread
and it's both rural and urban okay so
again she is right about this with
regard to the people with comorbidities
if my parents were not over i would not
be wearing a basket my wife would not be
wearing a mask
in our house i would be with my children
not wearing a mask because i am 36 and
my wife is a few years younger than i am
she's a couple years younger than i am
so this is again people are taking this
as
everybody panic and freak out okay then
dr burke suggested the kova death toll
could hit 300 000 by the end of the year
that would be horrifying obviously
that'd be a terrible terrible number
it would also be necessary to break that
down by age so we actually know how many
excess deaths
we have experienced on an age-based
level and what is your risk again the
big question here is not how many people
are going to suffer
that's a that's an important important
question but the real question is what
is your personal risk in going back to
work
that's the stuff the public health
experts should be talking about no one
i would venture to say the number of
americans who understand numbers like
000 you know if they're 300 000 deaths
if you ask the average american how many
people die a day in the united states
nobody knows that answer
the answer by the way 7 500 about 7 500
americans die every day
in the united states which is a pretty
large number of americans
i mean what that means is essentially
that every single year
in the united states 2.7 million people
die okay but
berks when when burke says the cove of
the death toll code at 300 000 you just
look at that number in isolation you'd
think you can translate that to risk in
your head that's not how it works here's
dr debra burks talking about
the overall number of deaths dr burks
you mentioned deaths the former fda
commissioner scott gottlieb said the u.s
coronavirus death toll could double
to 300 000 deaths by the end of the year
do you think that's possible
anything is possible if we don't have
all you know public health is called
public health because it has a public
component
and we need all of the public to help us
get us control of this virus
okay and again you know the the notion
that
you know the the notion that simply
stating raw numbers or putting out vague
data like well it could something bad
could happen
that is not helpful not in this latest
scott gottlieb who again has been a
guest on the show these people have been
guests on my shows okay so i really
respect their opinions
and they have more data than i am which
is why it's very frustrating when i feel
like the data they are conveying
is actually less specific than the data
they've conveyed on my own shows and
honestly
some of that i got to put on the media
who are not asking the only questions
that people truly care about what is the
risk to me
what is the risk to my children by age
by comorbidity how do we not have that
information what is the risk of various
personal activities
why is it that in order for you to hear
whether surfaces are transmitting this
thing
you're not getting that on face the
nation you're getting that on this show
the answer is
not much when it comes to schooling why
is it that the only people who are
discussing
at length the studies are not the people
at cnn who are just writing stupid
chirons
it's people like me who are actually
looking at the studies from switzerland
and iceland and australia
and here's scott gottlieb saying we need
to treat teachers
as front line workers we have to think
of teachers as front line workers again
all of that is fine but the notion that
teachers are at inordinate risk of
contracting this thing from children is
nuts teachers are at more risk
of getting this thing from going out to
like a normal restaurant and eating
indoors than they are of getting it from
kids by virtually all available data
here's scott gottlieb
so there's anecdotes and experiences on
both sides of this debate
i think to to counsel enough caution
that if we do reopen schools i think we
should try to i think many parts of the
country will have that opportunity
we should take every precaution to try
to prevent outbreaks and that also
includes protecting teachers teachers
need to be thought of
as front line workers in these
situations and given given proper
protective equipment
and ways to keep themselves safe in the
classroom okay
there are ways that if you are
particularly vulnerable that is the case
but how about this how about this how
about for the moment the teachers unions
stop with their crap
and let a bunch of younger people in the
classroom to teach and if you're worried
then zoom into the classroom as my
friend john podhorts suggested now the
reason that i've gone on about this for
so long here
is because there's this push now for new
lockdowns
by a variety of different sources and
there are people who are suggesting
lockdowns and then as an economic
solution they are suggesting that we
just pay endless amounts of money none
of this is a solution
none of this is what was preached at the
beginning the goal posts have shifted so
wildly
at this point and if you think that the
vaccine is coming from heaven to save
you
if you think that one day we're all just
going to wake up and the vaccine is
going to be ready
and it's going to be january 2021 and
the entire american
population is just going to be
vaccinated and boom this is no longer a
threat on the horizon as opposed to this
sort of becomes background noise
i don't know what to tell you even the
washington post doesn't have your ain't
going to hold your hand on that one
i'll explain in just one second first
with everything going on right now lots
of people are asking if it's even
possible to buy life insurance
at all the answer is yes it is still
easy to shop for life insurance right
now
in fact if you have loved ones depending
on your income you probably should right
now you could say 1500 bucks or more a
year
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies when you're shopping
for a policy that could last for a
decade or more the savings really do
start to add up
so what exactly is policy genius well
it's an insurance marketplace built and
backed by a team of industry experts
here's how it works you head on over to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much coverage you need you can
compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price
step two you apply for the lowest
possible price and step three
the policy genius team handles
everything paperwork red tape
soup to nuts policy genius works for you
not the insurance company
so if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll take care of
everything for you
they even have policies that allow
eligible customers to skip the in-person
medical exam and do it over the phone
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across over
600 reviews on trustpilot and google as
well so
if you need life insurance head on over
to policygenius.com right now get
started
it could save 1500 bucks or more a year
by comparing quotes on their marketplace
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it is nice to get it right
all righty we're going to get to more of
this in just one second even the
washington post is like guys if you're
waiting for a vaccine you could be
waiting for a while
but first if you are not yet a daily
wire all-access member you are missing
out gang
i'll access it's our most exclusive
membership tier featuring behind the
scenes access to us
the podcast hosts as well as writers and
special guests all access members are
also given early access to new daily
wire products
as part of that i'm excited to announce
our brand
new limited count collector's edition
baseball bat oh yeah this is a real
thing there's a real thing guys check
that out
look at that right there engraved daily
wire on that in collaboration with
pillbox
bat company you can metaphorically
destroy arguments
using this battle so you can hit
baseballs with it because baseball is
indeed
the greatest sport no matter what mlb
does to try and social justice warrior
its way out of being america's at
national
pastime this bat
it is handcrafted here in the united
states emblazoned with the daily wire
logo this running bats will each be
engraved with the individual number in
the order they were produced from one to
one hundred
these bats currently only being offered
to our all access
membership tier so join or upgrade now
before they are all gone text the
keyword baseball
to 83 400. we'll send you the link to
check out this
limited collector's edition bet if
you're not yet an all access member
coupon code access will get you 20
off right now all access members also
get to participate in all access
livewear one of our daily wire hosts
hangs out with you for a live discussion
yesterday very special live stream the
daily wires on jeremy boring who is a
space nut
watch the return of the spacex dragon
capsule and crew with all access members
host a discussion with them afterward
again
text keyword baseball to 83 400
to purchase your collector's edition bat
get 20 off all access right now with
coupon code access that is baseball to
83.
400 and coupon code access
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so the reason i'm focusing on
this is because the status quo is not
sustainable okay we can't just keep
spending money like this
we cannot keep pumping out trillions of
dollars in cash we don't have we cannot
pay people to stay out of work
this is not the way that a free economy
runs it is not the way a free country
runs
frankly and let's be honest the reason
that you saw
millions of people in the streets over
george floyd i would hazard to say
some of that was about real do-gooderism
by a small group of people and some of
it was you locked us in our homes for
three months and then you told
us that we are doing good for the world
by partying in the streets if you look
at the video
half of it was a party people were doing
yoga classes people were doing dance
parties
and they were being louded for it by the
media and it was all young people
and then you had a spike among young
people and you know what maybe in the
end that's not such a bad thing a bunch
of young people got it and got better
maybe that brings us closer to her
immunity maybe it does maybe that ain't
all a bad thing
okay but there's this idea out there
that if we just wait for a vaccine to
remember this thing started as flat in
the curve to not overwhelm the system
so we did that then it became well you
know we want slow spreads we don't
overwhelm the system okay so we mostly
did that
then it turned into okay what if we just
crush the virus with lockdowns
not going to happen gang again you're
comparing apples to oranges when you
look at places
that never had a high level of seeding
in the first place if you look at a
country
that only had a couple of cases or if
you look at a country they had the asian
strain of this pandemic as opposed to
the european strain of this pandemic
there are two strains one is much more
infectious
then you are you you're comparing apples
to oranges and by the way even in many
of the places that originally had only
the asian strain
now the european strain has been
reimported and you're seeing case growth
but
is the vaccine going to save us all
according to the washington post quote
in the public imagination the arrival of
a coronavirus vaccine looms large
it's the neat hollywood ending to the
grim agonizing uncertainty of everyday
life
in a pandemic but public health experts
are discussing amongst themselves in new
worry
that hopes for vaccine may be soaring
too high the confident depiction by
politicians and companies that a vaccine
is imminent and inevitable
may give people unrealistic beliefs
about how soon the world can return to
normal
and could lead to resistance to simple
strategies that can damp down
transmission and save lives in the
short term i would also say that if you
are if you are
of the belief of vaccine is absolutely
imminent this will also lead you to
believe that you can hide in your home
and be paid by the government until the
vaccine comes
i by the way i have much more faith in
therapeutics than i do in vaccine
i have a lot of faith in therapeutics
we've already seen the hospital
death rate dropped by like 80 percent
according to oxford
because of drugs like rendez-severe
because of simple tactics like not using
ventilators nearly as often
by using by by using machines that can
measure your oxygen
levels as soon as you get into the
hospital so we know faster exactly what
is going on with you and there are
certain treatments that have just gotten
better
there are new therapeutics that are set
to come online i know israel is
examining a therapeutic right now that's
already fda approved
that they say could theoretically reduce
the impact of coronavirus down to
essentially a common cold which would
mean this is this is over you know there
there are therapeutics that could come
along here
but counting on the vaccine is like the
magic day that is a mistake
according to the washington post two
coronavirus vaccines entered the final
stages of human testing
last week a scientific speed record that
prompted top government health officials
to utter words such as historic and
astounding pharmaceutical executives
predicted to congress in july that
vaccines may be available as soon as
october or before the end of the year
as the plot line advances so do
expectations if people can just muddle
through a few more months the vaccine
will land the pandemic will end
everyone can throw their masks away but
best case scenarios have not
materialized throughout the pandemic and
experts foresee a long path ahead
jonathan grad an assistant professor of
infectious diseases and immunology
at harvard university t.h chan school of
public health says it seems to me
unlikely that a vaccine is an off switch
or a reset button or you go back to
pre-pandemic times
or as columbia university virologist
angela rasmussen puts it it's not like
we're going to land in oz
the declaration that a vaccine has been
shown safe and effective will be the
beginning and not an end deploying the
vaccine to people in the us and around
the world will test and strain
distribution networks the supply chain
public trust global cooperation it will
take months or more likely years
to reach enough people to make the world
safe for those who do get a vaccine as
soon as shots become available
protection won't be immediate it takes
weeks for the immune system to
call up full platoons of
disease-fighting antibodies many vaccine
technologies will require a second shot
weeks after the first
to raise immune defenses immunity could
be short-lived or partial
well then it seems to me that the
media's focused on the vaccine and the
idea that a vaccine is going to be the
be all end-all
has been deeply irresponsible has it not
i mean
it seems like maybe we should have known
this up front so that we can make
provision for the now would that not be
a smart thing to do
a vaccine that mainly lessens the
severity of the disease might be
directed at older people and others are
great at
greatest risk for the worse outcomes one
that prevents infections well but
doesn't work as well in older people
might be directed to younger people we
just don't know is the bottom line
according to paul offit director of the
vaccine education center at children's
hospital of philadelphia
he says if you're talking about throwing
arms around each other sitting with 67
000 people at a philadelphia eagles game
i'd imagine that would take a couple of
years
a couple of years again
the the notion that we are going to be
like ever we're gonna be locked down
until magical vaccine comes is just
not correct it is just not right you
know who knows it's just not right
the german population so there's been a
lot of talk about the evils of
anti-lockdown protests in the united
states you saw this from the media
these look at these barbarian
anti-lockdown protesters
who are only losing their life savings
and their businesses and their
feelings of of empowerment and freedom
in the united states
those are those crazy people by the way
15 000 restaurants apparently have now
shut and will not reopen
that is a lot of dead dreams right there
that is a lot of unemployed people
but but if you protested in the united
states the media declared that you just
wanted to kill grandma
if you protested for george floyd based
on the statistical anomaly george floyd
represented
and based on the idea that black people
are an existential threat in the united
states the media celebrated you
while you violated all pandemic rules if
you went to grandma's funeral then you
were selfish
if you went to celebrate john lewis's
life you're good because john lewis is
an important figure
if you went to a funeral for grandma
then you were very very bad
and mostly if you're an anti-lockdown
protester you're basically akin to a
terrorist because you were stumping for
grandma to die
okay so what do you make of berlin
exactly according to the bbc
around 20 000 people joined the berlin
protest on saturday
organizers had built the event as a day
of freedom from germany's restrictive
lockdown measures that includes a
mandatory masking order
protesters the outlet noted carry signs
that said things like we were being
forced to wear a muzzle because the mask
man's ape
a seemingly surprised bbc according to
daly wire said some participants were
from the far right
some were conspiracy theorists who don't
believe that coven 19 exists others were
ordinary people who simply object to the
government's approach to the pandemic by
the way you can always tell by the media
coverage
which side they are on right when it's a
when it's a protest that breaks into
riots that shut down all of los angeles
county for a week it's mostly peaceful
when there's an anti-lockdown protest
that contains a few nuts carrying i
don't believe in coven 19 signs
then you lead with that a few of the
marchers wore masks or maintained strict
social distancing in accordance with
germany's anti-coronavirus restrictions
police broke up the protest
there is a an uptick in germany that is
happening right now there's an uptick in
spain
as well the wall street journal pointed
out that there's been an uptick in spain
they reported 2255 new cases on friday
following the report of 2615 new cases
on thursday
and again just like in the united states
it's mostly affecting younger people
so people are not meant to live like
this nor will they live
like this now the media the media are an
uncomfortable perch most members of the
media
they live in bubbles i know because i'm
a member of the media you can create a
bubble around yourself
you're mostly dealing with other people
who have the capacity to lock down
you never have to deal with the
proletariat you know the people who take
buses to work
you know you don't have to deal with
those people and so if those people lose
their jobs well you know we always have
government programs for them
this is how you end up with martha
raddatz on abc news challenging steve
mnuchin the treasury secretary steve
mnuchin said
if you keep paying people 600 a week not
to work they're not gonna work
and uh martha rabbit's like are you
really really you think they're just
gonna stay home
yes that's called an incentive martha
here's martha raddatz not understanding
basic
human rationales
there's no question in certain cases
where we're paying people more to work
stay home than to work
that's created issues in the entire
economy but let me just say you have to
i want to interrupt you there for just
one second
it's not all the evidence a yale study
from this month
refutes that saying many economists who
have studied the benefits said that so
far they don't see
any evidence in labor market data that
the payments are affecting the rate at
which people are returning to work
during the pandemic
well i mean i don't even know how you
would measure that
it's not affecting the rate to which at
which people return to work
first of all there are a lot of people i
know who have not received their
unemployment checks yet
i know them right they're eligible for
it they haven't gotten the checks and
they still have to make the rent
so there's that also it is true a lot of
these businesses have not fully reopened
but one of the reasons they haven't
fully reopened is because they can't
staff up
and because of the lockdowns and nancy
pelosi went even further she claims that
people will actually actively forgo
600 per week to make 300 per week so if
the government offers you 600 bucks a
week you're gonna be like you know what
government keep your money
i'm gonna go to work anyway for 300
bucks a week nancy pelosi crazy person
on abc's this week but
it's essential for america's working
families and and
again to condescend to disrespect
their motivation is so amazing how
how insistent the republicans are about
a working family and they're 600 and how
cavalier they
are about other money that is going out
okay she's an insane person that's not
that's not looking down on working
families if somebody offered me more
money to stay home than to work i would
stay home wouldn't you
that's just basic human nature because
why the hell would i work when i can
stay home
it's more fun to stay home mostly
so you know this is but again this is
this is the narrative the narrative is
you can stay home forever until there's
a vaccine and the government will pay
you
which seems to me mostly political and
having nothing to do with actual
reality meanwhile by the way things that
you are allowed to do in the streets
are you can burn crap and apparently rob
people so this is exciting
so over the weekend minneapolis police
told people
they informed residents of the third
precinct to prepare to surrender their
belongings
according to a july 28th email provided
to alpha news minnesota also provided to
the daily wire
the minneapolis police department
offered prevention tips to residents
hoping to avoid being a victim of the
skyrocketing cases of robbery and
carjacking that have plagued the city
since george floyd's death in may the
email says robberies and carjackings
have increased in the precinct
cell phones purses and vehicles are
being targeted
some victims have been dragged assaulted
and some threatened with a gun
downtown and southwest minneapolis have
seen an increase as well we want those
who live and work here
to be safe the email then goes on to
list several tips that citizens can
supposedly use to protect themselves
which also includes like just giving
robbers what they want
don't fight with the criminal do as they
say also never leave anything of value
in your car
so well done everybody everything is
going incredibly incredibly well
meanwhile the portland rioters got
wilder as
some of the feds started to withdraw
from portland over the weekend fox news
reported more than 150 rounds were fired
one woman was shot in portland friday
night while protesters on saturday
some of whom appeared to impersonate
press through glass bottles and shine
lasers that city police officers
sent to quell the nighttime unrest
witnessed for more than two months
straight
some members of the media tried to
pretend that this wasn't happening
the new york times nicholas kristoff
claimed that peace had broken out
mostly peacefulness peacefulness
intensifying
everywhere our wonderful media telling
you that lockdowns are possible forever
we can continue to just pay money and
also riots don't exist that are figment
of your imagination
meanwhile by the way anarchists in
portland finally got to what they've
actually wanted to do for a while
they're just burning copies of the bible
book burning they're really just going
for it now they burned an american flag
and they burned
books these are the good guys according
to the media these are the ones who are
standing for the sort of change america
needs to see burning the bible
i'm sure this is all going to end
perfectly perfectly well
okay so what implications does all this
have for for the election
well here's the thing president trump
has a lot that he can run on
it's going to require him to actually be
focused as i have been saying for a
while
but it seems like there's a new movement
out there and it's a very weird
odd strange movement and that is to
cosplay revolution
over the weekend there's this new
narrative that has emerged and it's real
weird and it's a little scary
of democrats and members of the media
suggesting that if trump
doesn't win he's going to be forced to
leave by the military
and it's like at this point they're sort
of rooting for a revolution now
listen i think that it was idiotic and
horrible of trump last week
to essentially suggest that we should
postpone the election or that he could
postpone the election that's idiotic
obviously
but do i really believe that trump loses
he ain't gonna vacate the white house
and we're gonna end with like an armed
standoff at the white house
white house allah the coup in in the
soviet union against mikhail gorbachev
or something
like is that is that where i think this
is going no i don't think this is where
this is going but
democrats seem like eager for this james
clyburn who's very very radical over the
weekend
congressman from south carolina saying
that if trump loses he's not going to
peacefully transfer power
it's that they're rooting for for chaos
and and
dissolution i believe very strongly
this guy never had any idea
about being one to peacefully
transfer power i don't think he plans to
leave
the white house he doesn't plan to have
fair and unfettered
elections okay this is crazy talk but
if this is if you have created such a
villain
in the president of the united states
that it allows you to say lock down
forever
if it allows you to say that kneeling
from the national anthem is good and
burning flags is good and burning bibles
is good
and that he's such a threat to democracy
he's never going to leave the white
house i mean that doesn't allow you to
get away with nearly anything
april ryan journalist journalist
pseudo-journalist
she said over the weekend that trump she
also put this out there that trump won't
leave
and what what a what a journalist at
carroll what is april ryan when trump
went after her obviously he was only
going after her on the basis of race not
on the fact
not on the base of the fact that she's a
garbage journalist here's april ryan
uh maya angelou said if they show you
who they are believe them
the president has said before in many
tweets that he wasn't going he said it
months ago joe biden even acknowledged
it
and it's real so there's going to be a
split screen on january 20th
2021 if joe biden is now going to be the
46th president of the united states you
will have him
being inaugurated and and watching
police and
armed forces trying to pull donald trump
out of the white house
i cannot wait for that split screen uh
no no wonder she can't wait for that
that split screen again this is this is
the fantasy the democrats are living in
because if donald trump is the kind of
guy who needs to be pulled out of the
white house this way it justifies all
the nastiness all the bad policy all the
nonsense
that's been going on the last few months
in the united states there's only one
problem
trump ain't that and even and and the
situation in the united states right now
is is untenable no matter who is in the
white house
okay we'll be back here later today with
two additional hours of content a lot i
did not have a chance to get to this is
why you should subscribe over at
dailywire.com
meanwhile go check out a copy of my new
book how to destroy america in three
easy steps
huge national bestseller it has sold
over a hundred thousand copies
in various venues in various forms so
far
you can read it i think it's a really
vital read at this point in time go
check it out
right now otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinnerton
edited by adam syavets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about
i hope you'll give it a listen
you